if someone wants to campaign on trans
rights it seems to me what stone wants
to campaign on is what stonework wants
to campaign on I have a I have an issue
with the way in which it chose to
campaign because what we had always done
as I explained before was built this
very Broad
alliances with people and crucially
around homosexuality and husbands and
gays The crucial thing is actually
people have a view about homosexuality
and what you're not going to do is
change their view what you will do is
change the circumstances in which
lesbians and gays can live so the
crucial thing is to make a material
difference to the lives of the people
you're campaigning for and the way you
do that is to build these broad
alliances around bigger principles
so if what you're going to do and I
don't know what the right strategy would
have been but if you're going to build a
strategy around trans rights you have to
find a way of engaging with some of the
difficulties that it poses and that
self-id identity poses with so that what
Stonewall should and could do is to host
that discussion